ми українські полярники звертаємось до
російським ученим
24 лютого російські війська віроломно
вторглися в Україну наші мирні міста та
села зазнає артилерійського удару
і бомбардуваннями на даний момент не
залишилося жодного регіону нашої батьківщини
куди не прийшла війна загинули тисячі
мирних жителів включаючи дітей зруйновані
будинки дитячі установи медичні
інфраструктура міст ви тільки
вдумайтесь наші друзі наші сім'ї наші
колеги-вчені всі взяли в руки зброю
обороняють свої будинки від російських
захоплений
військові плечем плечу
висловлюють свою батьківщину
україні ваші війська ніхто не чекає і
звільняти в нас нікого вторгнення
росії схопила все українське суспільство
незалежно від національності та
мови якою ми говоримо ми закликаємо
вас публічно висловити свою громадянську
позицію
зробіть все, що залежить від вас щоб
негайно зупинити війну
розв'язану вашим керівництвом
виходьте на проти встаньте поруч
зупинити про своїх дітей від того, щоб
вони стали вбивцями і лягли в чужий
країні безславно це ваш останній шанс
зупинити війну в Україні